hi guys today we're gonna do a
spoiler-free examination of Tamaki I'm a
geeky a member of the big three and one
of these standout characters in season
four but first if you're interested in
learning more about the big three be
sure to check out my myrio explanation
video after this one
now when Tamaki was around nine years
old he was transferred to a new school
and due to his social anxiety was unable
to actually introduce himself to the
other kids as a result he was unable to
make any friends until a young myrio
appeared and approached him due to the
realization that they both liked heroes
now this was the start of a beautiful
bromance and as they grew older
Tamaki always admired muirios optimism
due to the fact that he himself was
quite lacking in self-esteem and self
belief but despite his lack of self
esteem Tamaki entered the best hero
school in Japan and alongside Mario they
are now widely considered as two of the
top students in the entire school now
during his studies Tamaki was scouted by
the pro hero known as phat gum to work
for him at his office phat gum said he
could see great potential in Tamaki
despite his weak mentality in fact he
often teased Tamaki about his mentality
something which he equates to workplace
harassment but in reality phat gum
believes that Tamaki's abilities are
above not just his own but also above an
entire team of pro heroes that included
people like Eraserhead
and roc lock now one of the things that
people love about Tamaki is the fact
that despite being one of you waist top
students he still suffers from the same
social anxiety and lack of self belief
that he did when he was a child now this
is a really relatable vulnerability that
I think a lot of people really love him
for because they can relate to him
additionally Tamaki's hero name which is
sun-eater was actually inspired by the
fact that Miriah said he believed that
Tamaki would outshine the Sun though I
think that was probably just a metaphor
the name of Amagi Kees quirk is manifest
and it grants him the ability to
manifest the characteristics of anything
he eats as long as it remains in his
system and after vigorous training at UA
he's capable of using multiple
manifestations at the same time the only
drawback that I can see of his quirk is
that he's limited to what is still in
his system and the reason I say this is
a drawback is because he needs to be
incredibly tactical he needs to decide
what he's eating before he's even gotten
into a fight and that can be a problem
if you're in a specific fight but
there's a certain food that you didn't
eat that day that would have been really
good for that fight also if he was
captured for some reason and had nothing
to eat he'd be pretty screwed because
there'd be nothing in his system that he
wouldn't have already digested and that
my friends was Tamaki ammaji he
explained in like two or three minutes
and if you like that video I have a
variety of similar ones on my channel
including me Rhea explained in one
minute Rock Locke explained in two
minutes
subscribe to the channel if you liked
this video I'd really appreciate it
peace